hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast understanding t-cell
responses in tuberculosis latest
research on a quantifier on TB at Gold
class presented by Jeff Boyle PhD senior
director product and assay development
North America's kiya Jen I am Kristine
Mahalo kebab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes and
sponsored by kaya Jen for more
information about our sponsor visit kiya
Jen calm before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green at Q&A button located in
the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question into the
box that appears on the screen we will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me in
welcoming dr. Boyle I will now turn the
presentation over to him
okay terrific thank you it's my pleasure
to speak to you today about our latest
product in the clinic Iran TV gold
product line called TB gold plus and and
I will be walking you through some of
the early development the goals that we
had in front of us in developing this
product and some of the latest research
that's coming out as it's being used
independently around the world so just a
reminder for those that are new to the
quanta Fearon lineup of Diagnostics for
TB it's this these products are not
directly Diagnostics for or tuberculosis
infection they are aids that provide
information on the venous sponsor that
can be used in conjunction with other
information to make a clinical judgments
as to the infection status of the
patient so a little bit of background
about tuberculosis when somebody is
exposed to TB
aerosols a number of things can happen
in the majority of cases the person is
able to eradicate that inspection and
and will never develop active disease
however in some cases people become ill
and develop TB fairly rapidly usually
the highest risk is within the first one
to two years after being infected and
then for the majority of people that are
infected they will remain asymptomatic
for years and and continue with the
condition that we call latent TB
infection and the real puzzle that we
all have to deal with is that it's very
difficult to understand
what outcome is going to happen after
this exposure but what we do know is
that the immune system plays a very
important role in in determining this
outcome and so when we think about
Diagnostics there's a number of ways in
which we can look at the immune system
to give us information about responses
to pathogens and more commonly in
Diagnostics we rely on the humoral
immune response or antibodies but in the
case of quantity Ron we rely on cell
mediated immunity t-cells and
particularly a cytokine called gamma t
and interferon and this has really
become somewhat synonymous with some
ated immunity and it's a very good
biomarker to use for T V because it's
very important in terms of the control
of tuberculosis infection but also that
it's a very stable cytokine and it's
it's often not present in in normal
situation so it's over it has a very
good signal to noise ratio and when you
look at the spectrum of TB infection it
goes from this exposure through to
infection and and then the bacteria is
able to replicate and and then the
immune response kicks in and can either
control that infection establishing that
latent infection or at some point to
come and and this proliferation of
bacteria is somewhat uncontrolled and
you can go on to active TB disease and
importantly during these periods of a
very low bacterial load you can detect
an immune response by a gamma interferon
whereas you need much higher burdens
typically in order to detect the
bacteria directly or the humoral
response and when you compare our test
methodology to the traditional skin test
they're very similar
in the sense that they are looking at
cell mated immunity to the bacterial
antigens except that one is done in vivo
by injection of material under the skin
and then these cytokines drive an
inflammatory response and you can
measure that by the establishment of the
of the reaction whereas with our test
it's an in vitro test and were able to
directly measure the secretion of these
cytokines after exposure to to the
specific antigens and it's really it's
remarkable that this skin test is has
been around for so long it was first in
the early 1900s and and really has
served us well but but certainly has
some drawbacks particularly around how
do you measure it
is it injury duration or is it the
erythema and this requires two visits
one for the injection and then two to
three days later to come back and
measure this response and it can be very
subjective in terms of of trying to
understand you know exactly where to
start and where and where to stop and
when you compare the positive rates that
you get with with our skin with the skin
test versus quantity Ron it's quite
remarkable the difference and this is
really a synopsis of that and and it was
the largest screening study done today
and this was in China a very high burden
country in which BCG vaccination is is
compulsory and what what we could see is
that the the positive rate was 10
percent lower and and really this is
something that that goes to the the real
power of our test over this the
traditional skin test and also points to
really our understanding of TV
prevalence because a lot of our
estimates about TB infection have really
come from
prevalent studies using the skin test
which has this issue with with cross
reaction to the vaccine and that was
really where we had started when we're
talking about the evolution of chronic
fear on this was in the early 90s was
the first commercially available
quantity run test and it was very much
an in vitro skin test we used largely
the same antigens that are injected
under the skin as in the case of the
skin test and then later uh first
registered in 2004 was really the first
big step in terms of the clinic their
own evolution and this was when we
replaced these very nonspecific PPD's
with very specific antigens that were
not present in the vaccine strains for
for BCG and so now by measuring an
immune response to these very specific
antigens were able to differentiate an
immune response to TB complex organisms
over vaccines so this really allowed us
to get that very high specificity that
is so important for Quanah Fearon and
then we we continue to innovate with our
third-generation registered and with the
US fda in 2007 and this is when we we
really converted the in vitro test from
a purely lab based test to one that that
could be deployed remotely by the coding
of the antigens onto these blood
collection tubes and now it allowed us
to draw the blood and and stimulate that
those blood cells remotely and because
we're using standard phlebotomy and
standard blood collection tubes it's
really something that was able to be
scaled and allow us to now sell over 30
million tests since then and and really
a good reason as to why this is one of
the best studied TB tests that there is
now with over 1,100 publications and
and it's been I mean it's been a very
useful addition particularly around the
performance but when we put this into
the context of the spectrum of TB as we
start from exposure and which the
infection could be eliminated through to
the development of active TB disease
really the skin tests and tests like
ours interferon gamma release assays or
egress giving you that that value of a
positive or negative there's really only
one piece of the puzzle which is why we
our intended uses so much reliance on
additional information where you can
look at the at the individual in terms
of their risk factors do they have
symptoms and and what other information
do can we bring to help us understand at
what point they argue that are they
likely to have a latent infection or are
they subclinical or have incipient T V
as they as they call this and and really
help to provide information to
clinicians to to make those decisions on
whether or not the treat at all or to go
down a preventive treatment strategy or
to go with a more aggressive multi drug
therapy in in a setting of active ONC
p.m. TB so really we we knew we had a
great test by the third generation but
we understood that this challenge that
was facing clinicians was one in which
we could add more value and so we really
had to think hard about how we could
possibly improve upon our tests and and
really came up with a few desired
characteristics in terms of our fourth
generation and we knew that of course we
had to maintain that high specificity
but we felt that looking at what places
where we can improve sensitivity would
be important and as it's an immune based
test felt that in the in the settings of
the immunocompromised those would be a
great place to start and as we had seen
this challenge that faces clinicians and
terms of understanding how to deal with
the TV and the patient we understood
that that people were already starting
to look to our test for more information
in order to help them form some
algorithms to understand how to treat
and deal with patients better so these
risk-based algorithms were being
deployed and and so you really thought
you know what other information could we
could we give to help clinicians with
this with this challenge and because
we're a global player we've seen over
the years that there was a lot of
different demands than in terms of
workflow and some standardization that
could could be brought to bear so that
we're all using the same tests globally
and so we we did some initial work in
terms of looking at how to improve the
performance and here's some very early
proof of concept studies in which we
were able to to really win out to try
and target some high-risk groups
particularly hiv-positive subjects and
and here's just a snapshot of some of
the study data in which we were able to
show that with with qft plus in the
setting of HIV we were able to see you
know somewhat of an improvement in that
setting and importantly we did not lose
specificity and I'll walk you through a
little bit how we how we designed this
here so in terms of the new product
format the detection of gamma interferon
is really unchanged it's an immunoassay
it's an Eliza based format in which we
we detect on a fear look at gamma
interferon and but what we changed was
our blood stimulation - so if you noted
during that previous slide there was
three tubes and so we have added a
fourth tube and our format contains four
four tubes the first one being a nil
tube which really has no antigens in
there that's whole and that serves as
our negative control and allow
understand a background level of
gamma-interferon and then buy with tv1
and tv2 these are our antigen containing
tubes and in the tv12
we put in peptides that are designed
primarily to stimulate cd4 positive T
cells and in our TB 2 2 we combine
peptides that are designed to stimulate
both cd4 and cd8 and our positive
control is a very generic stimulant of
pH a mitogen and this list serves as a
control that says that the handling of
the tubes and and the blood was correct
and and that the person is capable of
mounting an a gam interfere on this box
and we also brought in new workflows the
single to collection in which you can
collect the blood and we allowed for
this to take place up to 48 hours if you
transport the blood at 4 degrees it's a
very flexible workflow outlined here and
so it's really the same simple system
that has allowed us to really grow this
test around the world and now with an
additional workflow option in which we
can collect blood directly into those
for blood collection tubes mix them with
the stimulants that are pre coded on
those tubes incubate them to allow them
to make that gamma interferon to the
stimulants that pre coded in those tubes
and then measure that amount of gamma no
fear on in and Eliza calculate the
results and then and then allow the
doctors and clinics to make that
interpretation and and understand how to
use this and and treat the patients and
the alternative new option is to do this
in a single tube collection and and
transport that blood to a laboratory
where the blood can be transferred to
these four tubes and so when we look at
the amounts of gamma interferon that we
utilized to call a positive or negative
you
went with a very conservative algorithm
and so if we say that if there is 0.35
international units of gamma neuron
above background in either the TV one or
the TV to two and the positive control
can be any any level we call that
positive and conversely if both the tv1
and tv2 gamin if you're on levels are
below that threshold we and the positive
control works we call that negative and
if our positive control doesn't get
above the threshold of 0.5 international
units of a background and and the person
would otherwise be negative
we call that indeterminate and that
really is there to say that we can't
make a determination in terms of the
likelihood of TB infection so the big
question that we get is so why did we go
down the path of looking at adding cd8
antigens and and and why did we go from
a 3-2 format up to a 4-2 format and just
a little bit of background on cd4 and
cd8 so cd4 t-cells are very important in
terms of Selmy ated immunity and they're
really the helper cells to the adaptive
immune response including cd8 t-cells
and these see these cd4 cells recognize
peptides that are presented in the
context of MHC class 2 and this is on
specialized antigen presenting cells and
these are really the drivers of the
immune response and cd8 T cells on the
other hand are very specialized and they
recognize peptides that are shorter in
length and presented in the context of
MHC class 1 and these cells are killed
killer are known as killer cells and by
recognizing these peptides on the on the
surface of our ourselves they they're
able to recognize where an intracellular
pathogen is present and and then able to
help
to eradicate that infection and it's a
and it's no surprise that that they're
important in TB because TB is an
intracellular pathogen and there's a lot
of in evidence out there that that cd8
t-cells are very important that it's
they've been shown to suppress the
tuberculosis bacterial growth actually
has recognized more highly infected
cells and they're also able to directly
lies tuberculosis bacteria and it's also
a good way to think about cd8 T cells as
somewhat of a biomarker for
intracellular burden they're there as
the bacteria numbers increase it's more
likely to then see cd8 T cells and this
is why when when they've been studied
they they've been more frequently
detected in those later stages of
infection when bacterial burden is
increased such as in the setting of
active disease and also early when those
that bacteria is replicating before the
immune response is able to get on top
and control it and and then not
surprising where the cd4 T cells have
been compromised such as a setting it of
HIV they've also been more readily
detected and and in terms of young
children they also seem to have a very
special role in the immunology of TB in
young children because they are a
biomarker for for intracellular burden
they've also been noted to decline once
people are on treatment and indicating
that the bacterial burden is being
reduced and so when you put that into
this picture now what we can say is that
yes we'll still have our information
coming from from the results of the test
of negative and positive but now by
bringing in the addition of information
associated with where cd8 T cells could
be present this can now give us a fer
their insights into the stage stage of
the disease and particularly as it
relates to burden and our test is is is
measuring gamut if Erin and Eliza and on
its own it can't detect where that
gamma-interferon is coming from so if we
really want to get insights into cd4 and
cd8 t-cell I mean to you in and of
itself it's not really a well-suited
assay to do that and you would tend to
have to use more complicated system such
as Ellis pod or intracellular cytokine
staining with flow cytometry or using
tetramers with and they'd see in order
to get you know some specific
understanding of what t-cells are
producing of the cytokine and so when we
looked at at at our system what we were
able to do was by the addition of the
fourth two and by having different
stimulants within those two tubes we're
able to get a lot more information out
of the system and I'll just walk you
through this so on the left hand access
there we have the level of gamma
interferon and when we look in patients
in in some of the early development work
who you would say would be highly likely
to have elaine tuberculosis infection
they had been agra positive for many
years and very healthy and unlikely to
progress to active-active disease in
that setting these tubes really acted
like replicates and it wasn't until we
really went into these higher burden and
higher risk settings and particularly in
the case of of active disease that we
were able to see quite a different
response and we were able to see that in
that setting when we looked at the level
of gamma interferon that was being
produced to the C for optimized peptides
alone it tended to be lower than that
the level that when we had both the
longer and this
order peptides together for cd4 and cd8
t-cell stimulation so this now gave us a
very simple way of coming up with a
biomarker for cd8 t-cell involvement and
so we took this test forward into
clinical validation and as I was showing
in that that study that that's those
slides before it's it's quite a
challenge to understand TB infection and
there really is no gold standard for for
a chronic or latent tuberculosis
infection and so it's really only in
terms of understanding the sensitivity
that we we have to go to active disease
because there we can actually detect the
bacteria directly by a culture and and
say yes these are definitely people who
are infected so so really we have to get
an approximation of sensitivity in that
group and then specificity again because
we can't definitively say that
somebody's not infected all we can do is
go into two groups in which they really
have no risk factors identified for for
TB infection and they're they're healthy
and so in that setting we we just assign
anyone who comes up as positive as a
false positive and so we did numerous
studies for sensitivity approximation
around the world and what we were able
to show is that we had a very high
sensitivity in in in these studies sorry
this was specificity sorry we maintained
our specificity in multiple sites around
the world and really showed that that
first important milestone of not
compromising specificity was achieved
and what we were also able to do was as
I said originally we had multiple ways
in which we could look at the algorithm
for interpretation we went with the
conservative algorithm for sensitivity
in which we would take a test above the
threshold
either two but what we were able to do
in this cohort of very low-risk
individuals is to say what would what
would the results be if we were to take
a very conservative algorithm forward in
terms of false positives and what in
that setting what we would say is that
both the tubes would need to be positive
and so we provided this analysis for it
for information and and what can be seen
here is that if we look at the number of
positives in this very low-risk setting
here we saw that we had 20 positives
that were identified by the conservative
algorithm for specificity and this was
reduced down to eight when she took this
more conservative algorithm into
consideration and so about 60% of the
false positives were able to be
identified when when taking very low
risk profiles into consideration and
then in terms of sensitivity we did a
number of studies around the world and
and really showed that that we have a
very high sensitivity in excess of 94%
and that by using this very conservative
algorithm for interpretation we were
able to identify nine positives by of
the tb2 only and three that would have
been indeterminate if they had have been
interpreted by the TV one only so in the
setting of high risk and active disease
we were able to improve the sensitivity
of the test with these edition of the
patooty format and and particularly
these cd8 in our mix
population when we compared our new
versions of the old version we had very
good concordance between the two with an
agreement in excess of 98% positive
agreement and and in excess of 99% with
negative agreement and when you looked
at with TFT plus there was a few more
positives but of course this this was
not significant and what we were also
too able to show was when we go back to
looking at the levels of gamma
interferon in the different tubes so and
subtracting away now the TB one value so
that's what the cd4 optimized peptides
alone or the combination with T V 2 we
were able to now get a surrogate for
this isolated cd8 response and what we
saw was that this increased level of
gamma interferon in the presence of the
cd8 peptides was more pronounced as we
went up in terms of risk category so in
the very low lista to tend attacked more
like replicates in the mixed risk we
started to see higher levels of gamma of
Iran and in the act of setting out many
more patients st. showing this vile
market for cd8 t-cell involvement so of
course when we can take this information
into the context of risk now we have
another piece of important information
along with how how concordant these two
tubes are so the million dollar
questions then are are these good
biomarkers for recent infection in the
setting of these mixed risk populations
and and really how does this help us to
inform clinical practice and so we knew
that that there was a lot of work to be
done and and the independent studies
were really critical in terms of
understanding the value proposition here
with our next-generation test and so we
we supported a very large clinical
program now in excess of 35
and patience and we did this by
providing free kits or discounted kits
and really allowed independent
investigations to get access to the test
and determine its utility in their
various research settings and and the
first independent evaluation was
published in 2016 and and this study
really highlighted that they that they
saw importantly this maintenance of the
high specificity 97% and and very high
sensitivity of 88% in active TV settings
and importantly they had a very small
number of HIV contacted and all 100% of
those TB HIV co-infected subjects would
work they also were able to show a
reasonable correlation with with bond
appear on of 94 percent in a subset of
these patients and and really I think
what was I guess the first study and it
was really great to see this this
validation of the TV 2 and TV 1 signal
in which they were able to show that in
a setting of sneer positive TB they were
able to see this difference
significantly more often as compared to
smear negative TB patients and and
really also validate this this this
setting of it being a biomarker for cd8
t-cell involvement by utilizing one of
those much more difficult settings of
flow cytometry to identify that cd8
t-cells were in fact stimulated in this
setting and and there very early
involvement with us with HIV
co-infection and and really seeing that
that they they were able to pick up
everybody with with HIV co-infection
really suggesting that there was
value in terms of bringing in cd8
t-cells in the setting of HIV and there
was further work than looking at this
hope this cd4 cd8 signal and and the
setting of disease and again really
showing that this this cd8 t-cell
involvement was much more pronounced in
the in the setting of more of a high
severity tuberculosis and and again
really backing up that that there was
quite a distinct difference between the
controlled infection and and really not
seeing this cd8 t-cell signature as much
as in the setting of other active
disease and one of the studies that has
really I think set set the world
interest on fire somewhat is is that was
the first study done in contacts and and
this study was was was done in 119 skin
test positive contacts and they compared
Quanah fear on the third-generation to
the the new quantity on plus and we're
able to show that there these skin test
positives were very heavily impacted
most likely by this the BCG vaccination
in that 63 of these individuals were
negative IQ ft however 12 of these 15
negatives were picked up as positives
with with U of T plus and when they
looked a little deeper at these they
were able to to show that these weren't
just five millimeter screen test
positives these were rather than 10
millimeter screen test positives and
they were able to retest some of these
individuals and two of them actually
converted to quantify on pause
they're kind of 12 weeks and these were
both initially positive by EFT plus
would indicate that qt+ was able to pick
these up a little bit earlier and when
they then start to look at multivariate
analysis they were able to show that
being QFT plus positive had a stronger
risk association with aggregate exposure
time to the index case and and proximity
to the index case or not and I'll show
you a little bit more about this here
because when they then broke that down
even further and said what about this
cd8 biomarker this difference between
the TB to gamma interferon level and the
tv1 gamut of your own level
they chose of a value of 0.6
international units for no difference
and they showed that this biomarker now
was significantly associated with
proximity to the index case that's
sleeping in the same room and also that
it was associated with being of European
origin which was much more of an
indication that these individuals were
not likely to have been infected for a
long period of time so really suggesting
that this new test format could be a
proxy for recent infection and this got
WH o interested in the testing and in
their 2016 TV report they actually
specifically called out to a peak loss
and mentioned this study as it really
was a the first indicator that that the
cd8 t-cell signature may be able to
identify people at greater risk of
progression active TB because as we said
earlier that recent infection that risk
for progression is really the highest
within the first one to two years and
just going a little bit further into the
the notion that cd8 t-cells are a
biomarker for for bacterial burden there
was a study published looking at at the
outcomes during treatment and and this
was quite interesting where you
looking at the amount of gamma
interferon is being produced at at zero
months three months or six months post
treatment and and showing really that
the the TB 1 or the cd4 targeted
signature declined somewhat at three
months but then really leveled off over
six months and TV 2 also defined that at
each point but really the only thing
that was significant was the difference
between those two tubes so that cd8
signature of TB 1-2 was able to decline
at each time point and this was
significant at the later time points so
really suggesting that the the
difference between these two tubes could
be a biomarker for burden and had hence
treatment efficacy
now I'd also sort of talk a little bit
about this single tube and here was an
example of a setting in which patients
in in the UK not foreign 4615 patients
would had their blood collected with the
single tube and they had been having
some issues in terms of some of their
remote sites really you know handling
the blood and so they they were getting
in determinants a little bit higher than
what they would expect and so they
really wanted to see if the single -
setting could help them in terms of of
bringing that control back into a
central facility and what they were able
to show was that that they were able to
bring that in determining right down to
20 percent which was something quite
remarkable and we'd also done a lot of
work in terms of the formulation and and
how we produce our manufacture our tubes
and and we felt that this would really
help in terms of overall consistency and
reproducibility of the test and and we
did see a study published in which they
looked at the precision of the new test
and showed that the the Seabees
on the on the test was was really a half
of what it was with the previous
generation really suggesting that this
could add value particularly as you get
levels around that cut point and as I
mentioned in terms of specificity it's
it's it's it's very important to us in
the in the setting of health care
workers and and we had identified this
alternative analysis and and what we've
seen now is publications coming out now
looking at this in the setting of health
care worker screening and were able to
to look at at the specificity in these
health care workers with that have no
identifiable risk factors and and had
not had at least self-reported positive
by L TBI tests in the past and what they
were able to show was that that their
their positive rate fell from three
percent down to one percent when you
would use this conservative
interpretation in which you would
require them to be positive by both tv1
and tv2 tube so very similar to what we
saw in our specificity studies and what
they were also able to do was to show
that when they retested these these
individuals that they had a high a high
likelihood of retesting negative so
effectively now with with with 50 plus
with this addition of the extra tube in
this low-risk setting you now have more
information that could be applied to
help you with the identifying false
positives and as I said
one of our goals was really to look at
the performance of the test in the
setting of the immunocompromised and
we've now seen the first patient
populations of HIV since ending of HIV
co-infection published and this was done
in Zambian patients and and they were a
hundred and eight positive pulmonary TB
subjects and with 68 being HIV positive
and 40 HIV negative and when when you
looked at the overall sensitivity of the
test one of the the key differences here
was really that with TFB plus there was
no difference in terms of the
sensitivity so we got a very high level
of sensitivity let me get this pointer
here here 80% in the setting of HIV
negative and 85 percent in the setting
of being hiv-positive so very very good
data and and very different to what
their experience was with QFT our
previous version in which there was a
21% difference in terms of sensitivity
in the setting of HIV status very
similar to what we saw in those proof of
concept studies they were then I'll also
able to look at the sensitivity as they
stratified by cd4 t-cell count and
really showed that there was did not
seem to be an impact on sensitivity was
key ft+
until you've got below 100 cd4 t-cells
in which the sensitivity dropped at 50%
and this is really again in stark
contrast to what their experience was
with QFT in which it was impacted at
quite dramatically attending counselor
less than $100 to 23% so really
promising data in in a setting of HIV
and
and the improvements that that be cd8
t-cells can bring so when we think back
to what everybody wanted in terms of the
new test it's had to keep that high
specificity and really you know bring
bring forward some improved sensitivity
particularly in the setting of
immunocompromised really understanding
how how we could add more information in
terms of this base algorithms and and as
I showing you in the setting of contacts
really you know being able to identify
potential recent infection and then and
then really you know the big question
going forward is how does this help us
in terms of prediction of disease
progression and so overall there's a
there's already you know a number of
publications out I walked you through
walk you through several of those but
but more and more coming out in terms of
looking at validating both the
sensitivity and specificity being
specificity being unimpacted sensitivity
certainly being very very very high and
and then in terms of contacts really
identifying that that cd8 signals being
associated with exposure risk and and
proxy for recent infection HIV
co-infection really showing that the
sensitivity was not impacted by HIV
status and then the gang back to the
biomarker of bacterial burden showing
that this cd8 signature declining during
treatment and looking at our laboratory
workflows and and the potential
improvements there with with the
precision so as I said there's a large
number of studies really the big studies
in terms of looking at progression take
quite a period a period of time and so
we're a couple of years into these
studies now so so stay tuned
in terms of more publications coming out
examining the impact of the new test and
but really you know we're quite happy
with with the performance so far with
the sensitivity now around ninety four
percent and active pulmonary TV and
really maintaining that specificity
that's a hallmark of our of our
quantifier on test and and really
showing now that bringing in this new
cd8 T cell technology with independent
studies really showing how the cd8
t-cell involvement can can bring
information relevant to new infection
and the burden of t v-- but of course
you know we really look forward to more
research coming out now to look at that
at where this information can be applied
and and ultimately we continue to
innovate improve the manufacturing and
and really our our goal is to get robust
reliable results out there and for all
the settings that this test is that now
put to now globally so thank you very
much for that and and I am happy to take
some questions
thank you dr. Boyle for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
I'll have the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for so let's get started with our first
question
our first question of the day asks does
QFT Plus distinguish between active and
latent TB
so yes I'd say our test is not intended
as a something that would be used in
that setting but as we saw there is a
tendency now for for there to be a
higher detection of the cd8 t-cell
involvement in the setting of active
disease but but really we feel that much
more research is really needed in terms
of applying it to that setting thank you
for your answer our second question asks
why was festivity so important
yes so as I said throughout the talk
specificity is really critical to our
test and it's really because our test is
is used as a as a as a a screening tool
in the setting often a very low risk
individuals in low burden settings think
so here even having a specificity of 97
98 percent can lead to a 2 or 3 percent
false positive rate in which in those
settings most of your of your positives
are going to be false positives so
really trying to keep that specificity
as high as possible will reduce the
burden on people in terms of
understanding you know what to do with
these individuals and and really helping
them to target treatment
thank you our next question of the day
asks why combine cd4 and cd8 if you are
interested in cd8 only okay great thanks
yeah that's a that's a very common
question and it really came down to what
we saw during the development and really
what is underlying the innovation in qf
t plus and it was really that in in the
combination of both these long peptides
and the short peptides we were able to
see a synergy that took place between
the cd4 and the cd8 and Ana loudest
thing to see this signaling in many more
individuals than he would have had we've
just gone down the path of using that
the cd8 only approach
and since we have some time constraints
- this will be the last question of the
day and this question asks do you still
need the four tubes if the single two
tube blood collection is used
yes so the single tube collection is is
now an option that that we provide and
so what we do in that setting is that
the four tubes don't need to be present
at the time of blood collection but it
allows that the lab or the lobotomist to
at a time of their own choosing
so then transfer that blood to the other
tubes either remotely or in the
laboratory and and really this provides
flexibility in terms of the patient and
and the number of tubes available at the
site I would like to once again thank
dr. Boyle for his presentation I would
also like to date kya Jen for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through February
of 2018 you will be emailed from lab
roots letting you know when the webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again here soon at laberd's goodbye